had my port surgery on June 7th, they told me after that I had been given antibiotics. I knew I should
start probiotics, but I felt ill immediately and forgot to do so. On the outside might some of my
symptoms itchy, eggs in the type rash on my chest, torso, armpits, vaginal rectal, itch, and white
tongue be from that initial antibiotic. We took lots of probiotics through the month of July when I was
on a 5e antibiotics per staff, but those initial symptoms remain. I am following a high protein
low-card mostly meat and vegetables and fat. I do among two cups may go in a smoothie and
maybe an apple a day doesn't sound like yeast or candida. If so, how do I get rid of it?
It can be certainly a candida infection given, you know, your amount of antibiotic use. It can be
not just candida, just microbiota, just overgrowth of different things and imbalance
in your microbiota. So that's very possible. Also, meat on that many antibiotics quite possibly
have damaged your intestinal lining and cause
disnot only dysbiosis of the intestinal tract, but issues with your tight junctions of the
epithelial cells, it's called the link you got issues, and you certainly could have developed food
sensitivities. Maybe you had put sensitivity for that and this just brought it out to increase the
amount of antibodies that you had to different foods. It's not uncommon, even if person didn't have
take a lot of antibiotics. So you're not protected from damage to the epithelial lining of the gut
by taking probiotics. So probiotics can help if a person has to be on antibiotics.
Probiotics are definitely recommended and will be helped to manage the degree of dysbiosis that a
person will suffer from, you know, longer-term antibiotics. However, it doesn't give you protection
against the damage that you're going to get that's going to ensue on the epithelial lining of the gut,
which can then lead to, you know, things crossing the gut border that shouldn't,
peptides of foods crossing the gut border that shouldn't, and you developing antibodies to those foods,
and now you have to manage that and start working on healing that. So, you know, in a perfect world,
I would run the Syrex panel array 2, array 3x, array 4, array 10 a person that came to me with
these type of symptoms. You have to get to some causes, some reasons why I know those things can
be expensive. So a lot of people can't do those things. Then you have to decide how you're going to
try to handle those, try to, you know, clean up the most common food sensitivities, get rid of gluten
in your diet, get rid of dairy in your diet, see how that works to a food elimination type process.
So you have to work through those things, call it, they might be more appropriate.